although February is the shortest month
of the year that doesn't mean it's short
on great games to play which is perfect
because you're gonna need something to
do after you get stood up on Valentine's
Day here are nine of the biggest games
releasing in February 2023
set in The Wizarding World of Harry
Potter Hogwarts Legacy is a single
player RPG where players get to
experience life as a student at the
esteemed Wizarding School the game is
set in the 1900s 100 or so years prior
to the original book series and has an
original story created by the
development team at Avalanche software
this unfortunately means you won't run
into Harry Ron or Hermione during your
time at Hogwarts but you will get to
create your own character get sorted
into a house attend classes and Forge
your own wait for it Legacy but the game
is more than just school work your
character will get to explore the
Hogwarts Castle and the surrounding
areas trying to solve its many secrets
and Mysteries under the direction of
Professor fig while not directly
involved with Hogwarts Legacy JK Rowling
and her anti-transgender stance have
plagued the game and everything related
to Harry Potter the developers have
taken the step of making it clear that
Rowling had no direct involvement in
Hogwarts Legacy but for the complete
story read gamespot's JK Rowling's
anti-transgender stance and Hogwarts
Legacy I'll leave a link to the article
in the description Hogwarts Legacy is
releasing on current and previous
generation consoles as well as PC on
February 10th
atomic heart the debuted game from
developer mudfish is a first person
shooter that takes place in an
alternative reality 1955. the USSR has
defeated Nazi Germany thanks to advances
in robotics and now the Soviet Union is
using that Tech to make everyday life
easier that is until AI turns on the
humans and starts killing everyone
classic the gameplay of atomic heart
will have you firing weapons with one
hand and Supernatural Powers with the
other in true Bioshock fashion although
it may give the impression of a
Wolfenstein run and gun shooter early
previews of the game have shown that it
mixes its FPS action with some
souls-like inspiration so get ready to
practice patience while you wait for
each opportune moment to strike an enemy
you can travel back in time with atomic
heart on February 21st for current and
previous gen consoles as well as PC
lightfall is the year 6 expansion for
Destiny 2 that features a new story set
in the neon cyberpunk city of neomuna on
planet Neptune where people who escape
the collapse created a metropolis over
the past centuries without the last City
knowing lightfall will include new
enemies and allies another Darkness
subclass called Strand and updated
in-game features in an effort to help
New Destiny 2 players transition from
New Light missions into the rest of the
content Bungie is introducing Guardian
ranks this is a knowledge ladder where
players can progress through different
ranks that guide them through the game
according to the game's director Joe
Blackburn lightfall is quote the
beginning of the end of the light and
darkness Saga and for those who have
been following the story for some time
now it's a big deal current and last
generation console owners as well as PC
players can jump into lightfall when it
becomes available on February 28th
wanted Dead is a third person slasher
shooter hybrid from the makers of Ninja
Gaiden and dead are alive you play as
Lieutenant Hannah Stone member of the
Hong Kong police force zombie unit and
it's your mission to get to the bottom
of a major corporate conspiracy in order
to find the answers you're searching for
you'll use a wide variety of melee moves
and take out enemies from afar with ARs
SMGs lmgs and grenade launchers there
are over 50 unique finishing moves to
help you complete your police work with
style as you battle your way through
this low-tech retro cyberpunk dystopian
City you can dive into this quote love
letter to the sixth generation of
consoles when wanted Dead drops on
February 14th for PlayStation 4 5 Xbox
One series xns and PC
originally released on the GameCube
Tales of Symphonia follows Lloyd and
Collette as they journey to save the
world from Darkness the duo will meet a
number of allies along their Journey
like the wandering Aristocrat zelos and
percia a lumberjack who lost her
emotions together they will make sure
that Colette the current chosen one can
climb the Tower of Salvation and defeat
the evil deciens Tales of Symphonia
remastered will feature up to four
player co-op for its real-time combat
letting you and your friends cast magic
and defeat enemies together relive this
beloved entry in the tales franchise
when it comes to PS4 Xbox One and switch
on February 17th
similar to capcom's Monster Hunter
series wild Hearts tasks you with
hunting down the Furious kimono Beast
that inhabit the dangerous landscape of
Zuma and places a big focus on using
technology and stylish combat to slay
these gigantic creatures in our Hands-On
preview for the game Kyle Hilliard said
quote wild Hearts will feel familiar to
fans of hunting games like Monster
Hunter but I walked away impressed with
how big a swing this game is from Omega
Force and EA it doesn't look or
particularly play like any game the
developer or publisher typically
releases and I'm excited to experiment
more with the crafting system it's the
mechanic that will help wildhearts stand
out from the crowd and I enjoyed the
process of scrambling up a stack of
boxes I built leaping off the top and
bringing down a powerful blow on a
rampaging kimono you two can wreck some
giant monsters on current gen consoles
and PC when wild Hearts releases on
February 17th
for years like a dragon Asian has been
the one Yakuza game that Western fans
have been unable to get their hands on
unless they were willing to import a
copy or learn another language so that
they can navigate the PlayStation
storefront of Japan it's a Japan
exclusive that was released on
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 4 in 2013
but now it's finally making its way to
the West this year and has been rebuilt
entirely in Unreal Engine 4. set in the
1860s Keo a fictionalized version of
Kyoto ishin focuses on the fall of the
Samurai during a turbulent part of
Japan's history gameplay and combat
should feel pretty familiar for
returning Yakuza fans however there is
an absence of using items in the
environment like a parking cone when
fighting make sure you've sharpened your
Katana because like a dragon eachine
will be releasing on February 21st for
current and previous gen consoles as
well as PC
this month we'll also see the release of
some new Hardware in the form of
PlayStation VR2 however I won't be
diving into the specs of that on this
video instead we're talking about the
biggest game that we'll be releasing for
it Horizon call of the mountain is set
in the same universe as eloy's
adventures in Horizon zero Dawn and
forbidden West this time around players
are cast as Reyes a shadow kardra who
has been broken out of prison the game
is also not in third person like the
mainline games it's first person and of
course fully in VR in our Hands-On
preview of the headset and the game to
more Hussein said quote what stood out
to me about playing Horizon call of the
mountain was how it felt like an
amalgamation of different kinds of VR
Gaming experiences we're familiar with
it was part virtual tourism Park
climbing Sim part bow and arrow combat
game and a bit of goofing off with
object physics all in one these are all
things I've done in various ways plenty
of times before but having it combined
into one cohesive experience that looks
as good as Horizon call of the mountain
elevated at all Horizon call of the
mountain is releasing exclusively for
the PlayStation VR2 on February 22nd
to celebrate Kirby's 30th Anniversary
Nintendo has announced a remake of
Kirby's Return to Dreamland in addition
to all of the game's fan favorite copy
abilities returning the deluxe edition
will feature a new copy ability called
Mecca this allows Kirby to take a
mechanized appearance and attain all the
skills that come with that the Remake
will also allow up to four players to
play both the main game and all the
various sub games locally included in
these sub games are a few new titles as
well as popular ones from the original
game such as Samurai Kirby relive this
Kirby Classic exclusively on switch on
February 24th what game are you most
excited to play this February and are
you thinking about picking up a
Playstation VR too let me know in the
comments and we'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]